dans les forêts les arbres séquestrent
le carbone tout au long de leur
croissance et ce carbone va rester dans
le bois même si on s'en sert pour
construire des maisons ou fabriquer des
meubles mais qu'en est-il des forêts
d'algues elle aussi elle capte le
carbone mais c'est une dynamique qui est
moins bien comprises même l'étendue des
forêts dalgues et méconnues alors c'est
justement pour repousser les limites de
nos connaissances qu'une équipe de
chercheurs c'est donner rendez-vous à
Anticosti
elle émerge là où le fleuve se jette
dans le golfe du Saint-Laurent
la majestueuse
île d'anticosties
440 millions d'années d'histoire avec
ces immenses falaises et ces canyones
spectaculaires riches en fossiles
anticosties est aussi reconnu pour ses
écosystèmes côtiers exceptionnels avec
ses forêts d'algues et ses os riches en
algues microscopiques le phytoplancton
ça a été documenté qui a des forêts de
macroalgues exceptionnelles autour de
l'île antique aussi ça a été documenté
que ce soit apparemment les plus belles
et les plus grandes dans le système
Saint-Laurent
ces forêts sous-marines stockent de
grandes quantités de dioxyde de carbone
elles ont des fonctions écologiques
inestimables c'est des poumons
sous-marins c'est des zones qui vont
abriter beaucoup de bébés poissons de
bébés mollusques dans ces des nurseries
ils ont des rôles écologiques très
importants
la côte d'anticosties et le théâtre pour
quelques jours d'une mission
scientifique à grande déploiement qui se
déroule sur l'eau dans les profondeurs
du golfe du Saint-Laurent et depuis les
airs
dans ce grand laboratoire assez ouvert
des chercheurs vont développer des
outils pour mieux détecter ces précieux
habitats sous-marins et évaluez leur
capacité à stocker le carbone
[Musique]
le chef du projet Simon Bélanger dirige
les opérations à bord du coriolyse 2 un
navire de recherche dédié aux missions
océanographiques
la spécialiste en océanographie
biologique Fanny noisette et responsable
des expéditions de plongée et une
scientifique du Conseil national de
recherche du Canada va survoler la zone
à bord d'un aéronef
le Coriolis 2 passera quelques jours
dans le golfe du Saint-Laurent
il vogue vers le premier site
d'échantillonnage
Simon Bélanger en profite pour réviser
le plan de mission avec le capitaine
ça va être bon c'est juste que je veux
une autre station où on va pouvoir
nettoyer la Drôme si c'est plus que 50
matchs
[Musique]
dans les eaux côtières au cours des
prochaines heures à des profondeurs
variantes de 15 à 170 mètres les
chercheurs vont scruter les fonds marins
à la recherche de zones peuplé d'algues
donc plusieurs opérations qui vont se
dérouler aujourd'hui dans un premier
temps on va récolter des échantillons
d'eau à différentes profondeur donc ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle la rosette qui va
déployer
cette immense couronne qui porte des
bouteilles de prélèvement c'est la
rosette en question
[Musique]
les chercheurs commencent à sonder les
îlots d'algues dans les zones peu
profondes là où elles sont bien visibles
puis les appareils descendent plus
profondément
les eaux claires du golfe du
Saint-Laurent permettent aux algues de
pousser à de grandes profondeurs là où
il est impossible de les discerner à
l'œil nu
[Musique]
de son côté Fanny noisette profite du
temps plus clément près d'anticosties
pour faire une sortie en plongée dans
des zones côtières à peine quelques
mètres de profondeur auxquels le navire
n'a pas accès
[Musique]
il n'y a pas trop de vagues la fenêtre
météo est idéale pour aller explorer les
fonds marins
arrivés à destination on prépare
l'équipement pour la plongée
Fanny et Léopold partent à la recherche
des forêts sous-marines
[Musique]
alors nous on va cibler ce qu'on appelle
les algues brunes donc c'est des grandes
algues assez longues et on a
principalement quatre espèces ici on va
dire la laminaire sucrée la gare criblée
la Larry succulente et puis la laminaire
digitée ce qu'on veut déjà savoir c'est
où est-ce qu'elles sont en quelle
quantité elles sont là et surtout avoir
une algue qui fait 30 cm ou avoir une
algue qui fait 4 mètres de long mais en
terme de de biomasse donc la biomasse
c'est la quantité de matière dans leur
tissu mais c'est aussi par extrapolation
une quantité de carbone on veut savoir
est-ce que un pied quelle taille il fait
puis combien on en a sur les surfaces
qu'on explore voilà parce qu'elles ont
pas toute la même morphologie
les algues ancrées au rocher grâce à des
crampons se développe en captant
l'énergie de la lumière et en absorbant
le carbone inorganique le CO2 de
l'atmosphère
elle transforme le CO2 en carbone
organique quel stocke dans leur tissu au
bout de quelques années lorsque les
algues meurent une partie de leur tissu
dégradée retourne à l'eau certains vont
remonter à la surface d'autres sont
enfouis dans les sédiments
[Musique]
quand la plante meurt chez les herbiers
ou chez les mangroves les tissus morts
se déposent sur le fond les bouts morts
rentrent dans le sédiment et vont être
stockés sur des dizaines voire des
centaines d'années donc là on a vraiment
un stock de carbone organique dans les
sédiments
on parle alors de séquestration du
carbone de carbone bleu
[Musique]
sur le navire les échantillons d'eau
remontés à la surface sont envoyés au
laboratoire humide
les scientifiques et leurs étudiants
vont identifier les éléments biologiques
et chimiques et les nutriments qui se
trouvent dans l'eau ça les renseigne sur
la présence potentielle d'algues et de
phytoplancton
on va les filtrer puis on va voir
analyser les filtres pour savoir quel
type de particules on retrouve donc le
phytoplancton la matière particulière
qui va caractériser un laboratoire et
toute la matière 18 également la matière
organique le carbone organique le
carbone les nutriments qui seront
également mesurées
l'équipe à bord du navire s'intéresse
aussi aux propriétés optiques de l’eau
des instruments à la fine pointe de la
technologie sont fixés sur ce cadre
métallique il mesure la lumière dans la
colonne d'eau ce qu'on appelle la
couleur de l'eau
on veut savoir qu'est-ce qui va changer
la couleur de l'eau qu'on perçoit
au-dessus donc nous on regarde quels
sont les mécanismes à l'oeuvre dans
l'eau qui lui donne sa couleur
la couleur de l'eau varie en fonction
des matières et des particules qu'elles
contient c'est un indice qui détermine
la présence et la concentration du
phytoplancton
on peut parler de particules vivantes
comme le phytoplancton qui est notre
microalgue qui fait la photosynthèse qui
qui contient de la chlorophylle et
d'autres pigments donc ça c'est une
mesure qu'on va faire
pendant ce temps sur le bateau zodiaque
Raphaël note les coordonnées
géographiques du site de plongée
puis il recueille des échantillons d'eau
pour évaluer différents paramètres
5 mètres plus bas Fanny et Léopold
mesure les îles aux dalles
ils installent ensuite un cadre de
plastique d'un mètre carré cette grille
d'échantillonnage permet de déterminer
la diversité d'algues qui se trouve sur
le site et d'évaluer la densité de cette
biomasse
puis il récolte aussi des algues qu'ils
enfilent dans des sacs et ramènent avec
eux à la surface
ces végétaux seront triés comptés et
pesés
[Musique]
le retour à la surface est pénible
ton ordi on va voir mais attends je
récupère mes doigts d'abord
ces missions accomplie pour l'équipe de
Fanny qui rentre à Port-Menier il leur
reste une dernière tâche à accomplir sur
terre cette fois dans le secteur de Lens
au fraise
le décor est spectaculaire
mais ce qui intéresse les chercheurs ici
se trouve sur la plage ce sont les
algues dérivantes c'est pour ça qu'on a
choisi de venir Anticosti c'est pour ces
accumulations d'algueula parce que c'est
la preuve qu'il y a beaucoup de
biomassalgal autour d'anticosties qui se
ramasse sur les plages lors des jours de
grands vents comme aujourd'hui
donc ça avec des images de drones on
essaie de repérer à ce qu'on a des
radeaux d'algues dérivantes et où est-ce
qu'il s'envend pour essayer de voir
justement où est-ce que cette biomasse
c'est par extension où est-ce que ce
carbone va être amené
Rafael m'habille et ses collègues
déploient des instruments qui mesurent
la réflectance des algues à tous les 10m
ce travail permettra de faire
correspondre les pixels captés du haut
des désert avec la réalité sur le
terrain alors les algues sont un peu
sèches et qu'elles ont passé pas mal de
temps en dehors de leur milieu naturel
il y a de la dégradation des pigments
qui leur donnent leur couleur et donc
qui influencent leur spectre de
réflexance alors ce qu'on a sur la plage
ça s'appelle la réalité de terrain c'est
le point qu'on considère comme étant le
plus fiable
et avec un cadre d'un mètre par un mètre
comme sous l'eau un peu plus tôt les
chercheurs vont quantifier la biomasse
et les différentes espèces d'algues
la journée se termine alors aux fraises
au sol et en mer le travail des
scientifiques aussi tir à sa fin le
repos sera de courte durée la journée de
demain s'annonce chargée et intense
[Musique]
c'est le jour J à Anticosti
la mission scientifique des prochaines
heures vise à détecter les algues et à
mieux comprendre le rôle qu'elle joue
dans le stockage du carbone
l'opération va se dérouler dans la
bégamache près de Port Meunier et au
large de l'île d'anticostics
l'équipe de Fanny noisette est déjà sur
la route
c'est
une journée de technologie logistique et
humains qui sont déployés tous en même
temps
ces coéquipiers Léopold
interne et Christian Nozay sont fin
prêts pour la mission qui les attend
malgré quelques ralentissements on garde
le cap vers Port meunier
aussitôt arrivé ok Fanny et ses
collègues se préparent pour l'expédition
sur le golfe du Saint-Laurent
je sais pas
merci pour les bouteilles d'eau
destination pointe aux épreuves
les chercheurs impatients sont prêts
pour l'embarquement
cette fois ça y est
le moment du départ est enfin arrivé
en plein milieu de la baie Fanny et ses
collègues doivent affronter un
adversaire de taille
si il a travaillé mais ça crée aussi ce
qu'on appelle des moutons les Cumes sur
la crête des vagues et ça ça fait comme
du bruit pour les images qui sont prises
depuis l'avion ils sont accompagnés dans
la B par cet étrange embarcation qui se
profile au loin
une moto marine qui semble tout droit
sorti d'un film de science-fiction
Raphaël je t'écoute
ok nous on finit de prendre l'eau et on
vous rejoint au début du 37 terminé
aujourd'hui c'est le gros de la de la
mission Aldi wine où on a toutes les
mesures qui vont être prises en même
temps sur les mêmes points
la moto marine concentre ses activités
dans la bégamache puis elle va s'avancer
un peu plus au large avant de revenir
vers le quai de port meunier
comme c'est une moto marine modifiée il
y a des difficultés techniques qui vont
avec mais il y a quand même deux
personnes qui sont assises à bord avec
tout un équipement et qui sont capables
de visualiser des données en direct
ils se sont remis ils sont où hein
Raphaël est Jérémy mesure la profondeur
et le relief du fond marin ainsi que les
propriétés optiques de l'eau ils vont
aussi pouvoir détecter les forêts
d'algues
sur le bateau pneumatique Fanny et ses
collègues complètent les mesures prises
sur la moto marine en prélevant des
échantillons d'eau
pendant ce temps le Coriolis 2 lui vogue
de station en station pour prendre une
série de mesures
et l'avion du CNRC survolent ces mêmes
stations d'échantillonnage à 1000 mètres
d'altitude
à partir de l'intensité de la lumière
réfléchie il peut repérer les forêts
d'algues et les Blum de phytoplancton
[Musique]
sur le navire l'équipe de Simon Bélanger
valide les données recueillies du haut
désert
les mêmes mesures que la caméra fait on
les fait dans l'eau pour calibrer les
résultats
puis là on va terminer la journée en
faisant
des mesures de température
qui va faire des oscillations entre la
surface et 50 mètres
le scan Fish est traîné par le navire
grâce à ses oscillations il peut mesurer
sur une grande distance avec précision
des informations sur la colonne d'eau
température
ouais ça s'est bien passé on est rendu
on a fait quatre stations on a commencé
proche de la côte dans les eaux à 15
mètres ensuite 30 mètres 60 mètres 100 m
dans la bigamache le travail des
scientifiques est maintenant complété
on a réussi à faire tous les
échantillonnages qu'on voulait apprendre
toutes les échantillons d'eau toutes les
mesures qu'on voulait faire puis on
espère avoir de vos résultats à
exploiter
l'équipe file maintenant à Port-Menier
les échantillons sont acheminés au
laboratoire mobiles installés à l'Arena
municipal
les scientifiques filtrent et analysent
les échantillons d'eau récoltés dans la
bégamache et à bord du Coriolis 2
ces données seront couplées aux images
captées par la caméra et perspectrale le
long du littoral d'Anticosti
une image comme celle-ci les zones en
bleu vert dans le bas près des côtes
correspondent à un secteur peuplé de
banc de laminaire
[Musique]
la somme de toutes ces informations
permettra de calibrer les outils de
détection et éventuellement de
surveiller les écosystèmes marins depuis
l'espace une fois qu'on a établi de
relations entre ce qui se passe vraiment
ici sur le terrain et ce qu'on peut
mesurer avec les satellites les
satellites sont jamais fatigués comme
toujours des photos de la faire
d'ici l'an prochain une caméra
hyperspectrale sera installée à bord du
satellite pace de la NASA
elle prendra des images de la couleur de
l'eau des grands lacs et des océans à
quelques 800 km d'altitude ces images
auront l'allure de pixel grossiers
difficile à interpréter
grâce au travail réalisé à Anticosti on
saura à quoi correspondent ces pixels
des forêts d'algues des algues
dérivantes ou des blooms de
phytoplancton
cette connaissance fine permettra aux
chercheurs de suivre leur évolution
anticostie mais également ailleurs le
long des côtes canadiennes
si on veut comprendre l'impact des
changements climatiques on a besoin de
d'outils pour documenter ces changements
là
c'est vraiment une boîte à outils qu'on
développe qui permet d'étudier de nos
environnements quotidiens
on pourra aussi estimer le carbone qui
se retrouve dans les eaux entourant
anticosties et dans le golfe du
Saint-Laurent
notre bus est à partir de l'imagerie à
partir des photos et des images
satellitaires c'est de pouvoir estimer
le carbone et de le suivre dans le temps
[Musique]
ultimement les scientifiques espèrent
donc qu'on en vienne à mieux protéger
ses écosystèmes côtiers essentiels à la
santé des océans voire même qu'on fasse
de la côte d'anticostique une aire
marine protégée
antique aussi est déjà une réserve de
biodiversité et puis elle va être
inscrite sur la liste pour le patrimoine
mondial de l'UNESCO
donc évidemment vu les la qualité des
eaux ici la qualité des écosystèmes
côtiers ça pourrait être une belle
candidate